You don't have to be some body language
expert to see how uncomfortable these
astronauts get when asked the simple
question like, "Can you see stars?"
>> I wonder, do you still see stars in
outer space?
Yeah, I was actually just talking to my
crewmates about that today.
>> Yeah, I was just talking to my crewmates
about that today. About what? Like how
are we going to answer this when we're
asked, "Do you see stars or not?" These
are blatant signals of being
uncomfortable because they have to tell
a lie when he's touching over his ear
and grabbing his nose and the woman over
here she starts playing with her sock
and touching the back of her neck and
looking down [music] and off to the
side.
>> stars in outer space and I was saying I
haven't as many as I thought I would.
So, Reed? You know what? I'm going to
have to pass this one off to the expert
in the back. Did you notice the guy in
the back? He did this.
Meaning, shut up, pass me the
microphone, let me tell the lie. This is
not a normal mannerism to go to
somebody. We we have so much
illumination from the sun on the moon
and the earth right now. It's It is hard
at times to see stars.
>> Okay, that's an answer that any of these
astronauts should have been able to
answer that, "Oh, there's just too much
light from the sun on the earth and the
moon for us to [music] see stars." But
yet there was so much uncomfortableness.
Just like when the first Apollo mission
was asked about them seeing the stars.
Could you actually see the stars in the
solar corona in spite of the glare? We
were never able to see stars from the
lunar surface or on the daylight side of
the moon but I would not looking through
the optics. I don't remember seeing any.
And yet Don Pettit says, "Oh yeah, you
can see the stars and planets." And
there's more than stars, you [music] can
see planets. You can see moons.
>> So, which is it, NASA? Remember, this is
the organization whose acronym just
happens to be the Hebrew word for to
beguile, to lie, and to deceive. There's
a reason that Jesus said, "In the last
days, let no man deceive you." It's time
to start asking questions.
>> [music]